it's getting too intense it's like every
week you guys come out with a new way to
humiliate us
you guys want to have sex with our boobs
now
you guys want to squeeze our boobs and
fuck them
[Applause]
what are you doing
what guy was ever having sex with a
woman and was like ugh
this vagina feels terrible
oh
i wish i had another one that was
completely dry
i know what to do
no that's my heart you idiot
get your dick off my heart
you guys have gotten spoiled you have
too many options that's the problem you
have too many options you guys like that
it's not whack-a-mole
i'm a human being
i have feelings and dreams
and parents
you guys are pushing it
it's getting more like i just feel like
you never come back from that having a
man's
torso in your
face
i feel like one day one day i will be a
mother right thanks to the miracles of
egg freezing
one day i will be a mother i will be
holding my beautiful baby i'll be
looking down at my
beautiful baby's eyes we'll be having
this beautiful mother-daughter bond and
then i'm just gonna have a flashback to
just a dick
that's not how i wanted motherhood to go
down
excuse me i have to fix my hair after my
dick hit it
you guys are getting desensitized and
it's like i feel like you guys are
getting more violent toward us also it's
like the new thing you guys want to do
is the gagging thing
that sex with you
[Music]
you know that sir
[Applause]
oh
the end of that is that your thing
you like that internet
[Applause]
if you're into that just go to jail now
you're going to end up there eventually
would it you want to put your dicks in
our throats
until we
that's where i breathe out of you want
to fuck my oxygen supply now
is that what it's come to
do you even like me should i leave
like what is the psychology the
psychology of it is like yeah my big
dick's gonna make her gag you know what
else makes me gag a nyquil gel cap
it's not that big of a deal
you